nous avons eu un échange très franc et
très direct avec le directeur de cabinet
de du président de la République son
chef de cabinet
où chacun d'entre nous a pu prendre la
parole et pour exprimer nos inquiétudes
sur la zone grise dans laquelle on
rentre dangereuse
exprimez nos craintes sur la montée de
la violence et exprimer nos craintes sur
l'absence de démocratie dans nos pays et
nous avons appelé à ce que le président
de la République prenne une initiative
rapidement des initiatives pour sortir
de cette crise et notamment en redonnant
la parole aux Français par
l'intermédiaire d'un référendum quelle a
été la réponse
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la République
a entendu nos demandes c'est engagé à
aller transmettre directement au
président de la République et fidèlement
à respecter la démarche que nous avons
vu et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la République a demandé de
nous recevoir c'est ce qui nous a dit et
enfin il dit que
tout le monde attend aujourd'hui la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel et
donc le président de la République
aurait bien conscience de la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes
mais il faut maintenant attendre la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
pour que ensuite des initiatives soient
prises par le gouvernement le président
de la République mettant tout cas en
tout cas aujourd'hui c'est la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel le 14 avril
prochain qui reste la date à partir de
laquelle les choses pourraient bouger ce
qui veut dire que d'ici là il faut
maintenir la mobilisation la plus forte
possible et être le plus nombreux
possible jeudi prochain dans les
mobilisations mais donc vous n'êtes pas
beaucoup plus avancé qu'on arrive
finalement
par le directeur de cabinet du président
de la République c'est la première chose
et ce qui nous permet aussi de montrer
la cohérence de ce que nous portons
quand même depuis un certain nombre de
semaines c'est-à-dire l'exigence de
retrait de la réforme et l'organisation
d'un arrive je pense que c'est utile
c'est aussi de montrer en quoi des
parlementaires peuvent être utiles au
mouvement qui s'exprime dans le pays et
qui s'exprimera en propre fortement je
dis dans la rue voilà c'est c'est ça le
message également
j'ai comment j'ai expliqué mon directeur
de cabinet du président de la République
que le feu pouvait sous la cendre dans
notre pays qui avait pas de déshonneur
au contraire à retirer cette réforme je
lui ai dit que le groupe iode que je
présidais n'avait pas eu vocation par DT
de cœur à déposer une motion censure qui
a neuf voix près
était prête aller passer et que nous ne
pouvions pas continuer à gouverner notre
pays dans ces conditions pendant quatre
ans je lui ai dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
enjamber la question de la réforme des
retraites comme ça essayez de rétablir
un dialogue si elle n'est pas ce
préalable qui était de retirer ce projet
de loi pour une réforme ont été
cordialement reçu en tout cas écoutez
j'espère que nous serons entendus le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
République nous a dit qu'il attendait
tout comme nous la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel raison de plus de
remercier l'ensemble de nos collègues
qui se sont associés à cette démarche
collective rendez-vous donc le 14 et
ensuite et bien j'espère que si c'est
pas tranché par le Conseil
constitutionnel partiellement ou
totalement ça sera tranché par ce
retrait de cette proposition de ce
projet de loi voir un référendum ce que
nous demandons en tout cas nous
continuons à porter et de cette campagne
de signature pour obtenir les 4 millions
qui sont ici mais signatures vous avez
pas l'impression de faire le jeu du
président de la République en allant là
il montre qu'il écoute il vous a reçu et
finalement rien n'a changé
nous sommes partout dans tous les
rassemblements moi je vous dis c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je suis allé
manifester avec les organisations
syndicales il y a toujours une première
fois dans la vie c'est peut-être la
première fois dans ma vie où je vais à
l'Elysée avec mes collègues communistes
bien nous allons partout de façon à
faire prendre conscience au président de
la République il faut que tu es donc ce
projet
il y a un message que nous avons voulu
faire passer c'est dire au président de
la République
le pays est en crise fortement on le
voit tout sur le constat tous et on lui
a dit par l'intermédiaire de son chef de
cabinet on lui a dit que le fait de
retirer le projet de loi le fait de le
soumettre un référendum ce ne serait pas
une capitulation ce ne serait pas une
humiliation ce serait au contraire qu'il
se grandissent par rapport à ça et qu'il
puisse avoir une réponse à la hauteur
par rapport à la crise que le pays
connaît aujourd'hui c'est ce message là
aussi que nous avons pu porter et quant
au fait de le de le servir en allant le
voir mais nous pensons que c'est lui qui
est au cœur des décisions à prendre il
l'a montré dans une intervention
télévisée et par plusieurs déclarations
et c'est pour cette raison car ce qui
nous concerne c'est pas le cas de
bertrandailleur parce que nous concerne
nous ne sommes pas allés rencontrer la
première ministre parce qu'elle nous a
dit clairement que le sujet de la loi
retraite n'était pas sur la table et que
j'étais pour discuter d'un agenda
parlementaire parce que je voudrais dire
c'est que nous avons quand même une
certaine expérience politique comme on
dit chez moi nous ne sommes pas des
perdre de l'année et nous allons voir
celui qui a l'équipe en les décisions et
nous allons pas discuter tout de suite
d'un agenda parlementaire de l'année en
quelque sorte en quelque sorte je dis
pas ça pour Bertrand puisqu'il était
hier en quelque sorte c'est sans doute
pensé que la solution elle est dans
l'agenda parlementaire dans une nouvelle
pratique nous pensons que la solution
suprême elle est dans le retrait dans le
retrait du projet de loi et dans
l'organisation de référendum et ça peut
être initiatique du président de la
République
[Musique]